-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
Thanks for being here.
Well, guys, everyone is
still talking about
Oprah's special with
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle.
And today, Buckingham Palace
finally responded
with a statement.
Listen to this.
-"The whole family is
saddened to learn
the full extent of how
challenging the last few years
have been for Harry and Meghan.
The issues raised, particularly
that of race, are concerning.
While some recollections
may vary,
they are taken very seriously
and will be addressed
by the family privately."
-Just to be clear,
the news anchor didn't see
the note up top that said,
"Read through gritted teeth."
For those who aren't fluent
in "palace-speak,"
they're basically saying,
"We're sorry you feel this way."
The statement would have
sounded more sincere
if they didn't end it with,
"So...we good?
Okay. Alright, we're going to
split, so we're good.
It's cool."
Meanwhile, CBS is begging Oprah
to do another two-hour special
on Harry and Meghan's response
to the response.
So that's interesting.
Yeah, if Buckingham Palace
is just learning
the full extent of
Harry and Meghan's feelings now,
wait until they find out what's
been going on
with Prince Andrew.
And in "making the story
all about you" news,
Piers Morgan, who faced backlash
over harsh comments
about Harry and Meghan,
will depart his show,
"Good Morning Britain."
I think it was time.
Take a look at how
his last day went.
-You don't like Meghan Markle.
You've made it so clear a number
of times on this program.
A number of times.
You continue to trash her.
-Okay, I'm done with this.
-No, no, no.
-Sorry. No.
-Oh, do you know what??
-Sorry. You can track her
maybe, not my --
-No, no, no.
-See you later.
-I'm being --
-Sorry, can't do this.
-This is absolutely diabolical
behavior.
-That's real?
-Yep.
Piers quit while the rest of
the anchors were like,
"No, wait, stop."
I like how the desk is so big
that his walkout
took like 15 seconds.
[ British accent ] "Sorry.
Sorry about that.
Nope, sorry. Can't do it.
I just -- Sorry.
I just -- Wait.
Wait a moment till I
catch my breath.
Alright, sorry. Here we go.
Absolutely.
No, can't do it."
[ Normal voice ] That's right --
after months of criticizing
Meghan Markle for making
an emotional exit,
Piers stormed off stage
in an emotional exit.
That's right --
Piers is leaving,
and he asked to be taken in
by Tyler Perry
and given full security.
That's right --
everybody's still talking about
the Harry and Meghan special,
but in the U.K.,
people were shocked by something
else during the interview.
Watch this.
-Viewers in Britain apparently
shocked at the amount of
drug commercials on American TV.
In England, it's illegal to
advertise prescription drugs.
-One British viewer
posting, "Help.
Why are all American ads
about medicines?"
-And another wrote,
"I can't understand why
American TV ads are like,
'Ask your doctor for...'
Why would you be the one
to tell a doctor
what medicine to give you?"
-When they heard,
Americans were like,
"Oh, if you have
a problem with that,
ask your doctor about Adoravan."
In our defense,
half our commercials are
for fast food and soda,
so it makes sense
the other half are for medicine.
Americans are so used to
these commercials,
we use the list
of drug side effects
as a white-noise machine
at night.
It's like, "May cause abdominal
cramps, enflamed retinas,
nosebleeds, soreness of..."
[ Snoring ]
Meanwhile, every member of the
royal family is like,
"Actually, that Xanax sounds
pretty good right now."
But Buckingham Palace isn't
the only place
dealing with a major scandal.
Listen to what's going on at
The White House right now.
-President Biden's two German
shepherds are back in Delaware.
Sources tell CNN the dogs were
removed from The White House
yesterday after
a biting incident involving
a member of the security team.
-Okay.
Now, these are the types of
Washington scandals I've missed.
There you go.
Dog.
Apparently, Major was jumping,
barking, and charging at people.
Wow. You'd think after
the last four years,
The White House
staff would be used to that.
Yep, the biting incident
came out of nowhere.
I mean, who knew
a 90-pound German attack dog
would present a danger?
When Major heard
he was going back to Delaware,
he was like, "No, please,
a kennel, the pound,
anything, just not Delaware."
Yep, Major and Champ
have left The White House,
and Sunday night,
they're sitting down with Oprah
to discuss where
it all went wrong.
Major really must have
messed up,
because look at what was spotted
outside The White House
earlier today.
This is real. Can we zoom in?
Look at that.
Rudy Giuliani was like,
"Hey, that's my old bed."
Then Dr. Fauci was like, "What?
That's my old bed."
Then Eric and Don Jr. were like,
"No, that's our old bed."
Some entertainment news.
Yesterday, "Zack Snyder's
Justice League"
leaked on HBO Max
for about an hour
and played when people
tried to watch "Tom and Jerry."
They fixed the problem,
but if you missed it,
we have a special
sneak peek of the film.
Take a look.
♪♪
-♪ If I go crazy, then will you
still call me Superman? ♪
♪♪
-Not what I expected, but...
This is cool.
Over in Japan,
they're about to open
the new Super Nintendo World
theme park.
The park was supposed to
open last year,
but construction got delayed
when the plumbers
kept getting high on mushrooms.
It looks amazing.
They have a real-life
Bowser's Castle,
and every day,
Princess Peach escapes
and then does a
prime-time interview with Oprah.
And, finally,
speaking of video games,
I read that Sony wants to
develop a new gaming technology.
Listen to this.
-Sony has reportedly filed
a patent to turn food products,
like bananas
and other household items,
into PlayStation controllers.
The goal is to use a camera
to map out
virtual buttons on any object.
-It's going to be weird
when your friend is like,
"Yeah, I'll meet up
with you after school.
I just got to go home first
and play with my banana."